something big it sure it is holy
this episode's nice this was like gotta
be its most violent it's like a really
violent episode it starts off with right
in the middle of this battle yeah and I
forgot her name the girl Masha
but the Masha has brought up this Beach
this beast from the ancient world a
beach that even strangers Beach
well we already had that remember yeah
that's right the woman Island yeah and
yeah pretty much brings him to life is
just attacking the Candy Kingdom and
killed root beer guy and with a general
candy corn was that yeah yeah that's a
general candy corn Jenner okay Colonel
candy yeah I think that was it and had
to be a he's in charge and they're just
having this great big epic battle Finn
and Jake have disappeared and this thing
gets out of this giant force field
brings down like all these creatures
from the sky and they break open and
they're running towards them begin
sliced up and destroying a bunch of
these candy creatures and suddenly
finish they come in with that two-headed
elephant and it starts zapping the hell
out of them and they're both from the
ancient world and finally blows up that
thing and Marja gets knocked out and
she's in a coma and then they're trying
to figure out what to do and the
two-headed elephant just decides to
kinda try and make his own decisions but
doesn't know how so he goes to Martha
who still macomb and says I'll be your
friend while you're still in the coma
and then the leaf falls in the camp and
I was gonna eat them and oh but we just
look it up apparently the reason they
killed him is to give a reason why the
banana guards are so still so
incompetent yeah well we should get
someone else to replace him that I don't
know but then we weren't having episode
like James - I guess I guess so but but
thank him Jake and get himself out of
the ropes from the last episode of the
episode before so easily Abbey come on
well what has gotten to be been like
this important
swellow and jake has said you know
remember when he got the chip cutting
this tooth he said if he always did all
that stuff you know he wouldn't have
any challenges in life okay that's
that's the way around there
that's fine but ya know this episode I
really liked it because it was a really
massive battle but it was really funny
and it had its hide back into like this
story but that you know this ongoing
story but at the same time it also threw
in a bunch of that randomness and the
slapstick was really funny and I liked
it when they incorporated other
characters like I like when one of the
lasers gets reflective blows up Ice King
I love those little touches like that I
love when everybody gets brought back to
life you still just see root beer guy
like he's still dead I love to seeing
the elephant again Wow I'm sorry just
Mountain Dew just materializes on screen
here weird it's like you finally done
you drank so much Mountain Dew you can
make it just materialize out of nothing
can at all pretty much interesting
anywho um and the the Marsha at know
Marsha Marsha Marsha Marsha that's it
again Masha Masha
magis voice with the you know both the
normal girl voice and then boobs right
Nick voice under it sounds great
whenever she says anything like you know
okay well I I can work with that I can
work but you're gonna work with okay
with it that's great that monster is
great him trying to adapt to this new
world and then him in the elephant or
from the same place and their while
they're fighting each other they're
talking about how difficult it is to a
judge I even like the little thing at
the end where the elephant doesn't know
what to do and Finn's like just be your
own person and he doesn't know so he
serve goes off and days pass and he
hears the aunt who only knows to do what
he feels he has to do and the birds and
the the mama bird and stuff it's uh it
was strange but it was the somehow it
was both so tight and told such a
complete story and then it was also so
random at the same time and I really
liked it that's sort of what
as sort of what adventuretime a lot
respects is to me it where as sort of
getting divided up into is this gonna be
a serious big story episode or is this
gonna be kind of fun waste of time this
one was kind of both young and a part of
me would almost like to see it you know
more just totally massive and really
huge because I mean the character we saw
like one other time the magic character
and it's one of those things were say
she finally comes man she's kind of
taken out one episode okay I probably
could have seen this as - I think you
probably Co stretched it up into man
that could've been really neat yeah I
could see in this sense too because if
search starts in the middle which is
funny but at the same time I'm like this
is pretty massive this is pretty huge
sort of the same thing with the with ice
King's wife it's like I Christine two
episodes with that uh I can't felt the
same thing here but as is I still think
it was really enjoyable it's kind of
like the return of the king of like the
adventure time you know in eleven
minutes with jokes and random parts
thrown in so so not return to the king
at all just in eleven minutes with
random jokes it could happen and it did
something big and the last thing I'll
say I love when she was bringing the
creature to life and the cool visuals
like they're like the I hope the moon I
yeah cool and just the design of that
thing alone was great and again they
gave him both sort of a he was
definitely very intimidating but he was
funny too and I think that made him it
didn't cheap in him because everything
seemed in character wait I need to
process this yes so tell me more about
it's like a character like that wouldn't
get feelings and love and stuff at the
same time that's might hear him say let
me process this and so on so forth so uh
I thought was great I thought was a
really really fun episode actually now
that you say that yeah like to an extent
it almost reminds me a Treebeard yeah
with the whole hold on a second I really
need to take some time to process this
let me think you know
yeah I can see that a bit and I'm done
seeing that okay I thought I said about
that no I liked it I thought it was fun
difference again I like one thing I've
always liked about the show is I'm kind
of continually bringing back unanswered
questions or what happened to blanket
character like last episode or
sorry two episodes ago with the elephant
also none of know where elephant show
some birds like whoa wait a minute oh my
god we haven't seen you since like you
know season two you know and it's kind
of neat is you forget about some of
these one-off characters and then they
show up again it's like oh my god and
what they're always been pretty good at
is like with Zerg iakh ones their yak
left you're like oh well there he knows
whatever then he comes back and they
kind of close it or at least almost
bring a full circle with these
characters the elephant who knows only
you know war and being told what to do
it's now kind of free to do whenever he
wants but he's also going with this
person of like evil and everything so it
could turn into one of these where they
learn from each other or I'm very very
very curious with what they're gonna do
with it like yeah I saw my I really this
is something I can't wait to actually
see later on down the road what they do
with it well especially cuz you when I
saw that the first thing I thought is
okay he's gonna befriend her and he's
gonna be evil but I like when she says
you know join me and we can be
all-powerful and destroy the Candy
Kingdom no I will befriend you until you
wake up wait are you are you that
elephant no I want no part of you and
then he flies off with her and is sort
of like yeah I have no idea where
they're gonna go with that that'll be
fun you know even if it does turn out
whatever he turns evil or whatever it'll
be fun to see the process because they
don't immediately start there yeah or me
it could go in a totally different
direction so I think that's that those
are great opportunities there which i
think is gonna be pretty neat um a root
beer guy you know a character that kind
of showed up played a very minor part
and now he's gone like they're good on
Memorial at the ends yeah they're good
at bringing back characters to either
close them off
to continue their story when most shows
kind of ignore them yeah I mean think of
most cartoon or TV shows where they go
to some alternate area of the world they
meet four people or two people then
after that episode never see them again
even if this shows on for 10 more years
again 80s and 90s programming I mean the
status quo literally ruled everything I
mean you can argue it's still kind of
doesn't some shows but I think it shows
nowadays I've really branched out much
more and become a much more one big
story as opposed to we have to keep
everything episodic and contained yeah
or at least there's a lot more variety
oh yeah and that's one thing I really do
enjoy about the Fincher time so I'm very
curious what the hell they're gonna do
with that I did like a candy corn
shooting himself out of the cannon with
a little guys after him and he's like
good guys like huh boom no sorry what's
under the mouth fire s'en yeah that's a
little candy guys and I'm like I say
definitely the most violent um but but
the this last thing in the comedy was so
fast and so good and was such a good
combination of you know kind of
suspenseful and keeping the energy up
and then just really random goofy jokes
like I said when when he threw himself
in the can is you know like the ticket
different fire boy yeah like it's just
great and I love just keeping that
momentum going throughout the whole
thing
um I'm curious about that I don't
remember the giant guy's name and I
think it started with the G like I want
to say like grant or something uh but
when Finn stabbed him in the head I said
thank you yeah I love you sick thank you
and there's a boom and I'm like wow
that's kind of neat and touching in
artifice yeah it's like it I dunno what
to make of it just made me laugh cuz it
was so confusing I think it's one of
those things more along the lines of I
don't want to be awake I am so old right
now I'm ready to die yeah and you know
I'll do what I'm told and I'm okay with
that but thank you for anything all this
it gave me an honorable death yeah I
also like you know the little touches in
this - were like he's talking to the
elephant making the clock of Mali says
you gotta do whoops
you gotta go and do whatever you want
like the black of Mali Falls and you
know what's and he just keeps talking
and then like no the conversation like
he'll bring the guacamole back up oh
thanks yeah and he'll just keep talking
it's like you could have caught that you
miss nothing but it's like those little
touches just make it a little more
unique and a little more funny well for
me it felt almost like Finn cared 10
times more for this elephant than
anything else going on pleasure the
guacamole well yeah like he's like
cooking and all this stuff and in most
other shows they would have made a huge
deal out of it like oh my god oh my god
grabbing for me quick you know or
something like that protected it did it
well because he's hauling this elephant
to be himself and to go out and do what
he wants and that's like more important
to him than the guacamole you know I
really like that they could have turned
it into like they could have dragged it
out to some really long lame joke but
they used the joke very well how it was
and also showed I don't know how caring
Finn is ya know and um I dug it I I
thought it was a real good combo and I
thought was a lot of fun you just like
that use the word dunk a lot cuz that's
my name yeah well actually in the
comments someone did say that it's a
Sarah like this is like the fourth
episode in a row where Doug said
something along the lines if I dug it
you know why it's like the word it's
like the word has just really been in my
mind for some reason I just been
thinking about myself a lot I say yeah
you love yourself up maybe maybe I just
want to use as much duckiness as Doug
can Doug you dug dude dude